How you doing?
[Silence]
I want to share with you all a verse of
the Quran that I think 99%
or maybe even a 100% of us are already
familiar with. We already know this
verse and maybe we can examine this
verse and see how we can apply it to
ourselves more deeply.
Allah Subhanahu wa Tala said to the
prophet sallall.aii
Allah subhanahu wa tala is speaking to
our prophet, our messenger and he is
reminding him of the incredible
blessings that he has placed upon him
and given him. And one of the things
that he mentions is
that you were found by Allah or before
receiving prophethood, before becoming a
messenger, before receiving the Quran,
you were
poor
and
Allah
made you wealthy.
But the wording of the verse is more
general than that. He says
he found you
is different than
both of them mean poor.
But
means dependent
and in constant need.
That a person is a
that means that he is dependent and he
is in desperate need
from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala for
whatever it is.
Then he says,
he didn't say made you rich
or made you wealthy.
He said,
"And then made wealthy."
You notice the difference in the
wording? He didn't say made you wealthy.
He said made wealthy.
What does that mean?
How do we understand that? Well,
because if he would have said made you
wealthy,
that wealth would have been something
specific to the prophet sallall.aii was
it wouldn't have been something that he
could pass on. Rather, he said
made wealthy, meaning he made you
wealthy and he made others wealthy
through you.
So he not only made you wealthy but he
used you as a conduit to teach that
wealth to others. And again that wealth
is taught
that wealth is something you can learn.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
He explained to us what this verse means
because when we examine his life before
prophethood before the night of
how was he financially was he not well
off financially
he had was his wife many children
mashallah and he had a very strong
a very strong trade
and particularly
the trade routes from Mecca to Am
Mecca to what would later be known as
Medina, he was very well off
financially.
But after the night of
what started to happen to that physical
wealth,
it became more and more scarce, right?
To the point that
he and his companions had reached a
position where they were tying stones to
their stomachs
to try to block out some of the pain. of
the hunger that they were enduring.
Is that not correct? That's a big
difference, right? from being a well-off
merchant of notoriety to having such
famine that you are in a in a state of
perpetual pain that you have to tie
stones and rocks, slabs of stone onto
your stomach in order to dull the pain
just a little bit.
So what is this speaking about? He was
wealthy
and
he later became
you know in a state of extreme
poverty.
Alhamdulillah
it relieved itself at the very tail end
of his life sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
But he endured a time of extreme need.
When the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam passed away
when he died.
What is the physical wealth that he left
behind? What were his financial
situation when he passed away? Yes.
Huh?
Okay. He left behind.
Very good. Which is his his his mule,
right? And he also left behind what
else?
His armor.
His armor and his sword. Sallallam.
Look what he's leaving behind, right?
His armor and his shield. His his his
armor and his weapon that he used
countless times for the sake of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And then what was the other thing that
he left behind?
Anyone remember
his his shield? His actual shield. Where
was it?
Yahoudi.
He he he also had left his shield as
collateral
with a Jewish man that he took
on we say on the books, right?
For some grain for his wife's h
homes. That's all he left behind
physically. physical wealth,
right?
So what does that mean?
You were in a state of poverty
and you were then made wealthy.
Was it physical wealth? If he had passed
away before the message, before Islam,
would he have had a lot more to to
pass on? Yes.
physical physical wealth, right? Gold
and silver and property and
but the prophets and messengers they are
beyond and above
those physical things that they leave
behind. Our prophet tells us that
he said
the prophets when they pass away
their inheritance
is not left in the form of gold or
silver. They do not leave a single gold
or piece of silver behind as their
inheritance for their heirs. Rather,
what do they leave behind?
Knowledge.
And what is the meaning
of Allah found you before the message in
a state of desperate need and he then
made you wealthy and made your followers
wealthy through you.
[Silence]
He said
And so what wealth is he speaking about?
What is Allah speaking about here? He
was in desperate need of
and Allah gave him wealth. Wealth that
never decreased. It always increased
with every passing day. And that was the
wealth of knowledge. But more
specifically,
the wealth of contentment and belief in
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Listen to
this narration. The prophet sallall.aii
Wasam said,
he said true wealth
is not
the a collection of property,
the attainment and hoarding of physical
things. He said true wealth is wealth of
the heart, wealth of the soul,
wealth of the self,
a wealth that can be in no way stripped
of a person by anyone other than Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Now, isn't that
incredible? What is that wealth?
We will end with this inshallah.
I want you to think in your mind.
Imagine
the poorest person you can imagine.
Maybe some of us were that person at one
point or in our lives.
You were able to get as very very poor,
very very hungry.
You had a full meal of the most meager
food.
Okay. the, you know, just anything to
fill your belly. And imagine
simultaneously the most wealthy person
eating the finest steak,
the finest caviar,
the finest
es cargo, whatever it is.
They both finished their meal.
This one ate the most meager meal. This
one ate the most extravagant meal.
Tell me the feeling of fullness
that both of them have.
Are they different from each other?
Yeah. That feeling of being full. I'm
full. I can't eat anymore. Is it
different or is it the same?
[Arabic recitation]
We're not talking about the taste. I'm
not talking about that. Taste comes and
goes. That's feeling. That's an emotion.
I'm talking about the feeling of being
full. I have eaten a full meal. I am
satisfied with this meal. Is it the same
or is it different?
[Arabic recitation]
The experience of getting to that
feeling might have been very different.
Yes. The experience of the fine food and
the refined taste and the best of chefs
and the best of seasonings that exper
experience when the food was passing
over the tongue and the taste buds. Yes,
that might have been very different.
But at the end of the day they both had
the same feeling before that meal and
they both sat with the same feeling
after. The prophet sallallah.aii was
says in the narration of
he said
[Silence]
He said,
"The human being's meal
is a perfect microcosm, an analogy for
all of the life of this world.
No matter how much the person seasons
that meal and salts that meal and
refineses the taste of that meal, look
at the final results
when you look at the waste that comes
out of a person after they've eaten. Can
you tell this one had esargo and this
one had steak and this guy over here, he
just had potatoes and rice? Can you make
that distinction?
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam says
don't look at the fancy stuff at the
beginning. Look at what happens at the
end. It all ends up where? In the
sewage.
It all ends up in the same place.
That feeling of he has better than me is
nothing but an illusion.
When you were a child, did you not get
very excited over certain things that
came into your life? Maybe a toy that
you obsessed over that today you
wouldn't buy for two for for two
pennies. You wouldn't even look at it
today.
It has no value to you today.
Right? What changed?
What changed? When you were a kid, you
had that feeling of excitement.
Let's take two children. One of them has
a little doll made out of fluff and made
out of a a an old potato sack and the
other one gets the finest finest
toy that the world has to offer. The
feeling of excitement. Is it different
between those two? It is exactly the
same feeling. It's the same feeling. The
only difference is what
the experience or perspective. That's
the only thing different. The only thing
different is how you see it.
That's the only thing different.
So when you chase after these
feelings, you chase after these material
things,
there's no difference between that and
the child who was chasing after that
toy. It is the same driving force and it
is the same feeling of satisfaction upon
obtaining.
And this is why Allah tells us
The life of this world is only,
notice the wording, the life of this
world is only
a brief
illusory enjoyment.
It is brief and it in itself is an
illusion of enjoyment. Let's say,
imagine you have something that is
you've been exciting. You you've been
you've been pining over it for years and
you finally get it. You get it. This
today, tonight, right now, you got it.
Whatever it is, a million dollars, a
billion dollars, whatever you've been
thinking about, wherever your dreams go,
when you allow yourself to imagine,
imagine that. And then you get it. and
then you get a phone call with the worst
news you could possibly get.
Would you be excited about it anymore?
Or you got that thing and then you were
told, "Okay, enjoy it. You have one hour
to live."
Would you still have the same feeling?
No. Why not? The thing is right there.
You have it in front of you. And that
that news that you got didn't change
your immediate environment. So what
happened? What changed? Your perspective
changed. That's the only thing that
changed. It was said that Fun when he
had that dream about a child from Ben is
that would end his reign and his
kingship. It was said he never enjoyed a
good night's sleep from that day on. Was
said he never enjoyed a meal after that
day. Well, what changed? Nothing
changed. Only thing that changed was his
perspective. And that is why our prophet
tells us
the the
food that you eat, the meal that you
prepare is an analogy of the life of
this world. No matter how much you salt
it and pepper it and cook it and perfect
it and refine it, look to what it
becomes.
Look to what it ends up as. It ends up
as a feeling of satisfaction and then it
ends up in the sewer.
[Arabic recitation]